sir,
is the potter here?
Registration
We do have a potter
Registration here is
Can you use it?
My company id
Its company
It is not accepted as valid
Upon registration
Ash is that the case
Is wait
I feel like I'm carrying a police officer
clearance then sedula naku naku naku naku
The community
Tax certificate
or sedula
and police
Clearance clearance
Also cannot be used
As valid
identification
For registration
What is that?
What are the valid ones?
Ids are accepted to register
This is the list of its shortcomings
or document that can be displayed on
Election
Officer Officer
To process the registration
National
identification card
Under the philippine
identification system
Postal id card
Person with
Disability
id card
Card students id
O library card with a lakta of
Authority and the school
Senior citizens
id card
Land Transportation Office
Drivers
or student permit
National
Bureau or
Investigation
Clearance clearance
Filipin
Passport
Social Security System
Government
Insurance System
o grace unified
Multi purpose
id card
Integrated bar of
The philippines id card
License from
Professional
recovery
Commission
Provided by
National
Commission on
Indigenous
Peoples
In case of
Member of iccs or cockroaches
Barangay
Identification or
Certification
With a picture
And other valid
Government
Id issue
That's it
Now you know
You also tease your co-workers
Go to
Office of
Election
Officer Officer
Or wherever there is
Register
Anywhere
Program
Because your right to vote
Start
Upon registration
So hashtag
You register